do you think we'll see Marvel in the oh
absolutely yeah
oh no he does yeah absolutely I know
that for a fact
cut that out what's up reject nation
John Kyle Kyle at the Kyle Luhrmann on
Twitter Instagram but more importantly
fan theory channel go check that out on
their TV to be specific and theory TV
I'm screwing this all up yeah I'm sorry
what do you do over there I understand
you have many series well I mean I rip
off you guys a lot what's up furious
nation on Craig oh man and I'm Shawn
mock free that's the sincerest form of
flattery I'm trying to kind of form it
as I go but yeah we do a lot of fun
movies TV shows video game content we
have to we watch series which is
basically a reaction to old TV shows and
then we have a cooking show hell yeah
what do you cook all kinds of things we
made this weird noodle nest with eggs
for Jurassic world I mean we just make
whatever looks like it fits the movie
what are you gonna make for Captain
Marvel Kyle we haven't gotten there yet
well you best start thinking about it
because we've got a Captain Marvel
related video right here right now
probably something with stars and
protein okay so like a starfish on top
of a steak there you go alright so we're
gonna check out ten theories about
Captain Marvel's future in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe figure like this will
be fun because if there's anything worth
speculating about it's what the hell is
gonna happen to the MCU after the next
Avengers movie right and we're gonna
check out the new ant-man later on today
which apparently is explaining so much
about infinity war let's hope and just
before we happen to this one to remind
you guys we have an event coming up
that's right the real rejects we're
doing our first ever live event at the
arena City lounge in Hollywood very
excited we're gonna have Brienne
Chandler aka Miss movies well Stacy
Howard in attendance helping us out
gonna be shot a lot of film clips doing
sort of a modified version of brands
film therapy show really excited so come
on down get your tickets links in the
description box and we even accept movie
pass people so if you don't want to pay
that's amazing you can still show up you
know
I could use some theories about what to
expect from Captain Marvel this is
reaching the fringes of my comic book
knowledge so uh you ready you ready hop
into this let's do this let's do it Kyle
style mic still on so professional
alright does it raise it Captain Marvel
is coming to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe which is an extremely exciting
prospect and she'll make her first
appearance in her 2019 solo movie her
best movie will be set in the past
however in this video is more about what
will happen with the character going for
we at flick news
yeah don't forget to hit the subscribe
button for the best way to keep up to
date with all screen rants great new
videos what are you talking about my
performance kill thanos given what
happened in the post-credits scene of
this year's epic Avengers infinity war
countless fans are theorizing it will be
Captain Marvel who saves the day and
kills Thanos off as next year sequel the
scene in question showed Nick Fury and
Maria hill driving through busy city
streets when the mad Titans finger-snap
started to take effect on the world
people disintegrated cars and
helicopters began crashing and both fury
and hill themselves became victims of
the prune Qin Warlord's act of wiping
out all life in the universe but fury
managed to quickly use a modified pager
to contact Captain Marvel which was
confirmed when her insignia appeared on
the pagers display given how powerful
we've been led to believe she is there's
every chance she could be the one who
lands with a slice of killing blow on
the villain Thor came close to killing
fan oats with Stormbreaker an infinity
war and Captain Marvel is said to be
more powerful than even the god of
thunder
so if Thor was capable of landing a near
fatal blow on him the woman otherwise
known as Carol Danvers should certainly
be up to the task of finishing him off
yeah if you two are finished comparing
sizes quantum realm
there's a very prominent theory the cat
marble will in some way be connected to
the quantum realm the quantum realm is
the dimension we were first introduced
to in 2015's ant-man before briefly
revisiting it in 2016's Doctor Strange
we will be reintroduced to it in this
year's highly anticipated ant-man in the
wasp what I miss
we were just tiny it will have appeared
so many times afford vendors for would
suggest it's extremely important and
given the Captain Marvel is set to play
an extremely prominent role in Avengers
for the theory makes a lot of sense
how exactly she'll be connected to it or
what it will mean for the story remains
to be seen but there are a few potential
sub fairies the most extreme is that
she'll be stuck in there having been
vanished they're back in the 90s during
the events of our that only upcoming
movie then there's the idea that she'll
know about the realm and will make the
suggestion that ant-man heads in there
in an attempt to change history however
the most prominent theory is that she
will be the one to venture into the
quantum realm to use its power or its
ability to traverse time so she can
reverse the effects of Thanos finger
snap whether or not any of this comes
true remains to be seen you make sure an
Avenger knows well maybe like a third
string of Andrea was one of the founding
members leader of the Avengers it's more
than likely that phase four of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is going to be
the dawn of a new era in the franchiser
the likes of Iron Man Captain America
Thor the Hulk and Black Widow will
probably either be dead retired or
taking less prominent roles and with
that in mind other characters will need
to step up when it comes to keeping the
Avengers going and keeping earth safe
given how powerful she's going to be
there's every chance Captain Marvel
won't just be a part of the New Avengers
team she'll actually be the one to let
it and we think that would be pretty
cool
the theory is Carol Danvers will take
charge of the likes of spider-man Black
Panther Falcon Bucky Barnes and
potentially some new faces as the MCU
freshens up its roster and phases out
the old guard it would certainly be an
incredibly refreshing change to see a
female character at the figurehead of a
superhero franchise and you wonder why
you waited so long
Studios are adding more and more awesome
female characters to the MCU but none of
them have top billing as part of an
ensemble yet this scenario would
certainly see that happening back and
forth between you guys and sword I had
given you everything I've got a romance
in the comic books Carol Danvers has had
romantic relationships with a number of
different characters over the years some
of which are too interesting to ignore
on the big screen and this theory
suggests at least one of them will be
depicted in the future of the MCU one of
those characters is Marvel was otherwise
known as dr. Walter Lawson and he'll be
played by Jude Law in Captain Marvel's
solo movie laws character is set to take
the role of Danvers mentor in the MCU
which probably rules out a romance
between the two and that movie takes
place in the 90s anyways meaning it
isn't part of Danvers future which is
what we're discussing here other
characters she's been involved with
include the psychiatrist dr. Michael
Barnett CIA agent Michael Rossi
restaurant owner William Wagner and even
the villainous Hyperion in one timeline
the most interesting however was her
romance with James Rhodes which came
when I was using the Captain Marvel man
even Modi is of course played by the
brilliant Don Cheadle in the MCU and a
relationship between him and brie
Larson's Danvers would certainly be
intriguing thank you 25 year age
difference between the two actors
hopefully you can say my life over that
she'll unleash her binary powers Captain
Marvel is incredibly powerful in the
comic books and as we've already touched
upon in this video she said to be the
most powerful hero in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but she could become
even more powerful if this theory is
anything to go by in the comics she
possesses super strength speed and
durability flight and potent energy
projection and absorption capabilities
which is probably what she'll have in
the MCU to begin with but there will be
more to come stay down
Carol Danvers has used a number of names
in addition to Captain Marvel over the
years including warbird miss marvel and
most pertinently for this particular
point binary as binary Danvers could tap
the energy of a white hole over full
control
elation of stellar energies and as a
byproduct of that complete control over
heat the electromagnetic spectrum and
gravity as well as light speed travel
and the ability to survive the vacuum of
space
should she tap into these powers om Cu
brie Larson's character could become
more powerful than anything seen in the
MCU to date not just the heroes and that
would be a pretty amazing spectacle to
witness on the big screen and that way
it might be really good Wow
the guardians of the galaxy in this
year's Avengers infinity war several
members of the avengers met several
members of the guardian galaxy for the
first time the team of space misfits
stumbled upon Thor's body floating
lifelessly among the wreckage of the
Statesmen the ship first seen in 2017
thor ragnarok after Thanos and his
children had ransacked it to obtain the
tesseract Thor then spent the majority
of the movie with rocket group before
the trio headed to earth to join the
Avengers in their fight against the mad
Titans forces in Wakanda it's more than
likely there's an alliance between the
teams that will last going forward in
the MCU and some characters could end up
swapping teams a prime candidate for a
future role in the guardians of the
galaxy is Captain Marvel which has
happened in the comics
she's a cosmic hero who spends a lot of
time in space so it makes a lot of sense
that she would join the space-based team
and in all fairness they could really
use some more power because they're
lacking a true powerhouse yeah I'll have
to agree with the walking thesaurus on
that one of course she's still got to
join The Avengers so if this happens it
probably won't be for a few years knock
it off she'll create a new team like the
previous theory of her potentially
joining the guardians of galaxy this
theory would take a few years to come to
fruition as she hasn't even joined the
Avengers yet but it's the theory that
Captain Marvel will create a new team to
lead in the MCU some of the other teams
Carol Danvers have been a member of in
the comics include a force alpha flight
and the starjammers all of which would
exciting additions to the live-action
franchise there's so many cosmic threats
in the MCU of late the universe could do
with a few more heroic groups watching
out for it sure the Avengers keep tabs
on earth
and the guardians of the galaxy are
always on the lookout for trouble in the
cosmos but the more teams backing them
up the better Carol Danvers is a born
leader but both of the Avengers and the
Guardians have a number of characters
capable of leading a team without her
should she set up a live-action version
of a force alpha flight or the
starjammers for example the MCU would be
better equipped to deal with any given
threats that occur at any given time the
scroll secret invasion the annihilation
wave or another villain getting their
hands on the Infinity Gauntlet for
instance the iconic costume it was
something of a disappointment for some
fans when behind the scenes pictures
were revealed from next year's Captain
Marvel movie because brie Larson was
wearing a green superhero costume as
opposed to her comic book characters
current and more iconic red and blue one
in the comics Green is strongly
associated at the Kree and the simplest
explanation for Carol Danvers wearing a
green outfit is that she snags it from a
Kree soldier after gaining her powers
however there's a theory in fact in this
case it's more of a bona fide certainty
that she'll dawn the famous red and blue
one sooner rather than later in the MCU
when Nick Fury used his modified pager
to send a distress call to Carol Danvers
the icon that appears on the devices
display showed her star-shaped yellow
insignia on a red and blue background it
may actually turn out that she's wearing
red and blue by the time her 90s solo
movie comes to an end but since we can't
be sure that we're happy to class this
as a theory about Captain Marvel's
future it'd be an honor thank you
she'll get a trilogy if the future
importance of Captain Marvel to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is as huge as
we think it's going to be then this
theory is certain to come true and it's
the theory that brie Larson's character
will get her own trilogy of movies in
the franchise the only characters to get
trilogies in the MCU to date are the
flagship male trio of Iron Man Captain
America and Thor so a female character
getting one would be a huge step forward
in terms of diversifying the franchise
to date all three of these existing
trilogies have had their ups and downs
none of them have been consistently
brilliant 2008 Iron Man was great with
2010 Iron Man 2 and 2013's Iron Man 3
failing to live up to their predecessor
2011 for was passable in 2013 Thor the
dark world was forgettable 2017 thor
ragnarok however was epic and hilarious
and 2011's Captain America the First
Avenger while underrated was
underwhelming 2014's Captain America the
Winter Soldier however was absolutely
fantastic and 2016 s Captain America
Civil War was a fun action-packed
ensemble now hopefully next year's
Captain Marvel movie kicks off a
flawless trilogy that puts those that
came before it to shame and that's the
end of our video if you enjoy it what do
you think I have to into Captain
Marvel's MCU future let us know your
thoughts in the comments section below
and don't forget to Like share and
subscribe to Screen Rant to that like
this one
bye pronounced video looks like it took
a long time to make yeah which I mean
first off I just want to give them some
props because like the amount of footage
sourcing and stuff like that little
moments they gotta know we're gonna fit
for this I have a second clip to move
things along like top notch well done
got videos like that for a single person
might take a month hey yeah I like this
little list that we've got here so show
kill thanos I think that's not
necessarily what's gonna happen mostly
because I think everyone expects it yeah
and the MCU has now kind of made it
known that they're going to try
everything the power to make it
unpredictable as much as you can so it
makes sense that she would kill thanos
because she's definitely up to the
challenge that's all I keep hearing
about her is that she's so powerful
she's the only wanted to make it happen
I feel like whatever direction they take
it in will probably not be as simple as
oh she's gonna show up and like punch
him really hard or something her blast
him was what what I think is so crazy
and interesting about her characters
that she grew up on earth at least
originally and then most of her
character exists inside the cosmic realm
I feel like that's part of the thing
that draws me to like the things I've
learned about Captain Marvel that's one
of the most interesting to me yeah so
she grew up on earth as a human without
powers and then this one thing happens
and the next thing you know all my gives
her a strand of hair then she's got one
for all
that's exist
yeah yeah I think she's super-powerful
what I was kind of hoping that the x-men
would do is show rogue using her powers
which they never did hey they could now
if they acquire Fox which is up in the
air again it's always up in the Comcast
or somebody just come in and were like
we're gonna pay cash yeah I'm like who's
drug money did you launder to do this
people used to be upset that Disney was
gonna get rights to Marvel now
everyone's like please the quantum realm
I have never associated Doctor Strange
and Ant Man as having much connected
there yeah I mean I knew the quantum
realm made sense I never really thought
of doctor Strange's world as the quantum
realm I actually just watch Doctor
Strange and a couple nights ago again
and I wouldn't have just made the
connection intrinsically yeah I can
definitely see it I always saw that as
two separate worlds but I think it's
really fascinating because the idea is
that when you get so small-time
technically moves differently and going
into that level of weird science it
almost makes sense you can take in a lot
of really creative directions so I never
thought about her going into the quantum
realm cuz I again I know the origin of
Captain Marvel and I know how she ends
and I know the rebirth and all this good
stuff but I've always heard of her as
more of a cosmic entity and also like
with all that they're hinting that Ant
Man and the wasp is gonna have some
context clues for infinity war it seems
like the quantum realm is gonna play a
part in whatever this Avengers for arc
is gonna be sure so I wouldn't be
entirely surprised if that also includes
her and some blue marble always needs a
new direction to go in you know their
directions after this I'm sure
I feel like Marvel has this weird mantle
top hold right now world every phase as
they kind of keep the cutting edge and
there have been some phases that have
been more cutting-edge than others and
now yeah they have to keep finding that
new direction right every phase it's
always like I don't think there's
anywhere else to go and then there they
are they find a new place to go which
you know this whole thing about her
becoming the leader of the Avengers I
think could be a cool I think that is
the one on this list that makes the most
absolute sense because I don't think
Marvel cares as much about keeping this
a secret because let's be honest these
actors that are playing the core
original vengers they're not sticking
around we're not gonna keep seeing them
this makes perfect sense because she
does lead some of the New Avengers and I
believe she even leads the guardians at
one point she's very much the leader
definitely most powerful she could
probably take on all the Avengers and
said Oh Thanos and she was villain like
they would all be screwed
well that seems like it would be a fun
dynamic shifter too because like if
she's gonna become the leader of The
Avengers theoretically they're gonna
have to acknowledge that she is kind of
the first female leader for the
Cinematic Universe anyway and I got
imagine that that would create some fun
banter moment sure part of the fun of
Avengers movies or at least the earlier
ones is watching them kind of get their
[ __ ] together to work together yeah yeah
yeah and that could kind of tweak that
dynamic they brought up all these losses
I just had to make this note I really
don't want Scarlet Witch to go away me
neither and I feel like she another
chance to show yeah I'm not ready for
her to go away just yeah she'll be my
rogue if they get rid of her this soon
oh that's right and then they'll bring
her back for like kind of yeah Days of
Future you have to wait so they're
re-release and then you'll kind of get
like a cameo with her and that'll be it
was it worth it was it good the road cut
I mean you get 20 more minutes but no
not really
oh I'm not sure if they're gonna do the
romance thing mostly because we live in
a modern day and age where they're
trying to go finally down that route of
feminism and empowerment and female
strength and all that so I don't think
that they're gonna necessarily do this I
mean it is Marvel they do like to hook
up their characters and everything yeah
Black Widow has been a romantic interest
for like half the Avengers with the
popularity of Wonder Woman because it
was popular it was the only time good
thing in a DC the only one that's gotten
a fresh rating from everybody's Marvel
is already on top of stuff I don't think
they're gonna have four have romance not
really on anyway there's gonna be
relationships but not romantic
necessarily I would save the romance for
one of her standalone movies and some of
the sequels or something like that if
they're gonna go down that way because
I'm not opposed to any character having
a romantic story sure especially in
these movies I don't feel like it's an
important focus I think it would be
refreshing though if there was a single
female character that didn't have a
romantic it'll be great actually well
Anne I don't know I mean given her
powers and responsibilities like it's a
really time
right and hey who knows maybe she could
have a little less traditional
orientation anyway yeah yeah you know
that would be interesting one of the
theories that really excited me and this
list was the binary theory yeah I know
she might at some point hone in on and
unleash those powers yeah like binary as
a character seems really cool yes even
by some of the artwork they pulled for
this video
it'd be like the Dark Phoenix of Jean
Grey except good yeah I was gonna say
what does that mean does she just get a
little bit more intense but generally
speaking she's still on the right side
of justice I would say all of those
things and it goes beyond the kind of
mindset of Doctor Strange like it's like
what's out there more trippy and fluid
and yeah define see that's the stuff
that I really want to start seeing in
these movies especially the Trippier the
more out there sure especially as we get
into the metaphysical realms and the
quantum realm and the space opera stuff
you know we're not just saving earth
anymore the guardians of the galaxy okay
her forming with that makes perfect
sense because they do want to go in the
cosmic direction more than they have
more than just guardians like we were
just saying because she is part of their
team as well at one point I think that
would open the door if if Fox is
acquired by Disney that we could go and
do the Fantastic Four and we could do
Galactus which is a huge
yeah it's just hard to do so many of
these movies and have the stakes always
be that this person's gonna destroy
everything but that is a big big big bad
that I am very excited to see yeah come
to life someday yeah the green costume
it's obviously associated with the
scrolls it's st. Patrick's Day yes it is
because it's st. Patrick's Day a fight
crime still she's a big drinker she
wasn't in the comics but they're gonna
change things up in the movies yeah cuz
she's probably got it like a crazy
metabolism which means like she has to
drink a ton before you know any effects
even I mean Factory that sounds
scientifically accurate it's an
educational program is what each movie
is really I mean Marvel's yeah it's like
Sesame Street but for grown adults I've
in her child entertainment Oh creating
her own team yeah I mean artemiy doesn't
think that they're gonna give up on the
Avengers title because it is so popular
and everyone goes oh that's the big one
that's the one that all these movies
build up that's the umbrella right right
but Marvel does like these trilogies no
I don't know they need to make her make
a team like halfway through the first
movie do Justice League - yeah in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe
Batman is gonna join the team and yeah
this all makes sense I mean I'm sure DC
would be open to that I'm sure DC is
open to literally anything at this point
somebody marches through their doors and
is like I have a confident idea it
doesn't matter what that idea is I think
they'll take it the idea of her creating
a team I think is cool but I have team
fatigue now that's why Deadpool 2 was
actually so refreshing I get why some
people were frustrated by a certain
twist boilers yeah but I kind of
appreciated the way they handled the
whole team element in that movie because
as much as I was ironically as much as I
really liked the team that he put
together for the x-force it was nice to
not have to do that and I don't know I
feel like yeah we have a lot of teams
now and there's a lot of like I'm
assembling a team and now other
franchises and other media are all going
like we gotta have a team and I'm a
little tired the team we need a break
guys like I'm down with the idea that
she would have her own team I think
that's a great idea if she's not gonna
lead the Avengers yeah her leading the
Avengers is what I would like to see I
think that's also one out of all the
Marvel movies coming out and this
includes spider-man I know because I'm a
huge spider-man fan I'm most excited for
them to finally make the Black Widow
movie because hmm not only does she not
have superpowers she doesn't really have
anything except training yeah and we
need that not just because it's a female
lead movie but it's a solo movie without
powers and that is something Marvel just
hasn't really done yet and you know red
Sparrow wasn't actually very good when
we saw that trailer we're like oh it's
Black Widow but now there's still room
for Black Widow to come in and take that
mantle so I would be down to see that
movie yeah cuz I feel like the joke
about Black Widow is always yeah you got
Thor and Iron Man
these dudes with crazy powers and and
black widows here to to punch and fire a
gun a few times and do that leg thing
but I've seen her outfit yeah we've all
seen her out I think would be cool to
have her Center a movie where she really
gets to shine and where her abilities
really do come to the fourth look where
you're like even though she's not a
super-powered person she's still a
formidable and a worthy member of the
team not out shown by you know god of
thunder stuff yeah I mean I feel like we
sort of got like a pre prequel in us in
a sense to what her kind of movie should
feel like in Captain America the Winter
Soldier yeah yeah yeah there's like
espionage yeah I want to see more that
we all know that works
make it happen Marvel oh yeah it goes
without saying she's gonna get yeah in
the video I was thinking why don't
assume the big deal yeah of course
she'll get a trilogy but it's the fact
that she's female and she's getting a
trilogy yeah most of that movie randomly
tanks every terrible would be the
biggest surprise honestly if that movie
didn't do well I know that they've gone
up up up up and they can't keep running
on gas forever but I feel like Marvel as
much as their popularity has always been
on the up they've still had figuring out
to do they've still had phases that are
a bit more lackluster than others and
sure there's still ground for them to
cover and they're still things for them
to strive for I think I think the thing
is them even their worst movies still
have enough money that they've made from
them that they always get sequels unless
unless there's a licensing issue of
course yeah it's like unless this does
extraordinarily bad I think I think
there's gonna be a few Captain Marvel
movies at the very least but yeah guys
what's your favorite theory or do you
have a theory that wasn't discussed in
this video hit us up in the comment box
below we might take a look at it but
anyway you guys can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell because the subscribe button
doesn't do its job for some reason the
Kyler men on Twitter and Instagram go
check out fan theory TV that's got a
cool watch along some cooking shows
various nerdy delights plus you know
Kyle's lovely mug go give him some
support and keep an eye out for our live
event July this
vii 6:00 p.m. Saturday come see as
people we would love to have you there
and as always Cheers